Especially with a platform technology
that you can go after many different
product applications,
but you ultimately get valued most
importantly on the first application you
bring forward and as an entrepreneur you
have limited time and limited resources,
so you need to choose well and drive
deep into clinical and regulatory
validation for that first product.
Now in order to make that often really
painful decision about what to invest in
and what to leave on the side,
at least for awhile,
there's many aspects of a certain
product you need to think through.
Obviously market size plays a role,
a technical fit to need plays a role.
As I'm looking at new ideas,
I often try to follow some of the advice
I once got from Bob Langer,
who has been very prolific.
He's started roughly 50 companies out of
his lab,
I think at this point.
And I've had the honor of starting two
companies with them.
Um,
among the other kind of rules of the
road.
He shares his first look for a platform
company.
If you're going to build a company,
make sure that if you're successful in
one area,
it can create value in a number of
adjacent areas because that really
justifies bringing in the investment,
building the whole infrastructure,
not just for one product,
but potentially for many,
but within that it's crucially important
and perhaps most important to select an
opportunity that has a very clearly
defined first product opportunity that
you have the ability to drive to a major
value creation,
a event like a regulatory or clinical
approval.
As you're building a business,
you ultimately get valued on that lead
asset you're carrying forward,
so it's important to have a platform but
not to lose focus within that platform
and make one crucial bet that ultimately
can drive the early success of your
company.
What really gets me excited is
developing new therapies that can help
patients.
In order to do that,
you need to think through who exactly is
the patient you're trying to help,
what disease do they have,
and what kind of clinical trial could
you design that really proves that
you're giving a benefit to that patient.
When you do that,
you have to think through what type of
therapy is practical,
how's it given,
how frequently and by whom and in order
to understand that whole pathway from
basic discovery to delivering an actual
therapeutic requires a great variety of
different skills you must bring together
and early in our startups,
what we've done is first focused on some
of the fundamental biology,
but then defined who are the experts
along the way that we're going to need
to engage in order to advance all the
way through the development regulatory
and clinical process,
and I can encourage young innovators
enough to think about engaging product
development experts and clinical experts
early in the discovery process because
that really shapes what you're trying to
discover and what you're trying to
create.
That can ultimately help the patient.
As I interact with a lot of young
entrepreneurs who are thinking of
starting companies,
the most important piece of advice I
like to give them,
particularly on the technical side,
is find someone who has totally
different skills from you that you can
trust and will challenge you.
It can help you think through the many
aspects.
It takes to address to build a business
or create a new therapy.
For me,
this was when Bob Langer introduced me
to David Lucchino,
who in 2005,
uh,
became my co founder of my first startup
and he took me out of the lab,
dragged me into the hospital and really
started meeting nurses and purchasers
and doctors who were people I'd never
really interacted with at a deep level
so I could start to understand if were
to develop a new product,
who are all the stakeholders this
product would need to satisfy and how
can I understand all of their
incentives,
all of their constraints.
Because ultimately to get a new product
to patients,
you need to understand the whole
delivery system.
It's must go through in order to bring
that forward and who must become
champions.
And the only way that was going to
happen is by that early interaction in
introduction to David who brought a
business and marketing and totally
different background.
But we challenge each other.
We have mutual respect and it's let us
build now to businesses that have have
brought a number of exciting things into
the clinic.
In order to enter this industry,
uh,
particularly as an entrepreneur,
as a first timer,
and that was straight out of Grad
school,
I went into my first startup and really
had no experience developing products.
The advice I'd give is really to engage
people who've gone through that product
development experience very early on.
They'll have a lot of rules of the road,
a lot of mistakes to avoid a and can
really help make you successful even if
you don't have the deep domain
experience yet.
And it's amazing how much young
entrepreneurs who have a passion and
enthusiasm and some really big ideas can
engage in drawing people who have deep
experience even before potentially they
could afford them as consultants or
employees.
I think as entrepreneurs we're dreaming
big.
You can share that energy,
share that vision,
get people involved,
and really bring in a fantastic folks.
At the very early stage.
One lesson that was imparted to me early
in in my previous startup was to think
very critically about all the testing
and all of the features that a medical
device must go through to be successful.
We were essentially creating a new
technology to try to make medical
devices safer,
reducing clots or infection was
ultimately our goal for devices that
went into the body.
Now we thought initially as
technologists about the new feature we
are creating and how powerful it was and
how helpful it could be,
but as we started to work with
experienced product developers,
they made us realize that these devices
were designed with a certain application
in mind.
They needed to perform certain functions
first and foremost,
and as we're adding our new technology,
as we're making our advance,
we couldn't do any harm to the current
standard of care as we're adding new
features.
I knew an existing product and that even
applies in thinking about not in any way
falling short of the standard of care in
some aspects as you're trying to
improve.
Another aspect is very important and
experience product developers can really
help you understand that process in
order to drive new innovative medicines
to the clinic.
Uh,
a critical aspect of this is developing
a strong intellectual property position
because of the great resources required
to advance the medicine.
It can be hundreds of millions of
dollars to advance from concept through
trials and even billions of dollars
before ultimate launch of a product.
In order to justify those kinds of
investments,
one needs to be able to have a product
that one can protect for a period of
time on the market.
The benefits of the patent system are
essentially it's a trade for a period of
time.
You're granted that right?
To be able to have exclusive access to
sell a certain medicine,
but in trade for that essentially have
to disclose to the world,
here's exactly how we did it and it can
let the world start thinking pretty
quickly about how can they do better and
at the end of the day,
whole fields of science,
advance new medicines move forward and
as things become generic,
things continued.
Medicines continue to reach a broader
and broader patient population.